وبذكاء على مينسك وويلكينسون
باب واحد جورج إن على الأرض للحقوق و
هذا سمين هو بستاني
[موسيقى]
نحن سوف
و
[موسيقى]
وفي تلك الأنظمة تواصل الأعمال النووية
الإرهاب في زابوروجي النووية
محطات الطاقة خلال اليوم الماضي
وحدات المدفعية
القوات المسلحة لأراضي أوكرانيا
قصف المحطة في 3 ش كان في المجموع
- 17 قذيفة ، اربع منها
حصلت تحت أسطح المبنى الخاص رقم واحد
حيث يتم تخزين 168 مجموعة من عندنا
رجل ذكي جدا متخصص في الطاقة
تدقيق haiti كلاكما لا تحبس بسبب
أن ما هو واضح وذهب إلى السيناريو والمرونة
وإلى اليمين يتم تشكيل الفيل والجحر الروسي
المسافة أعطيت إيقاف كنت تعتقد و
تغذية فان روبل الطاقة لكاي
هل تريد كرسي دبوس بحالة ألف شخص
يجب أن يطيع من أجل مزورة لا
سوف تكون مهمل مرة أخرى أمس
ستكون هناك طرق ، أنا لست المفاتيح
محطات مرئية لروسيا